welcome to another technology Tuesday
today I'm talking about how to find your
notes in Evernote I got a great question
from one of my youtube viewers love you
guys
Sarah who wrote in the say I was curious
in how you name your notes containing
the receipts I currently use neat to
store and organize my receipts and save
important files slash business receipts
to Evernote as well among other things
do you add additional comments in the
note containing the scanned receipt so
is a great question and one that really
relates to for me at least how do I find
the notes after I've scanned it in right
you scan something in your skin in a
contract an agreement a business receipt
and you want to be able to find it later
right that's typically the challenge
that people have so if you're you're
naming it what conventions can you use
so it's easy to find that later on there
are four main ways to find your Evernote
notes okay the first is through your
notebooks so your notebooks I treat us
folders in my computer folders on my
gmail I name them intelligently
according to the category that fits best
so for example I'll have a stack that
will be called travel and under that
Ojai berries notebooks so it might be
honeymoon it might be Europe cruise it
might be
North American tour whatever it is all
those notebooks separate and then inside
will be individual notes so it's easy to
scan and find those files that I need to
get access to the next one the number
two is naming your notes and I will do
this only when I plan to browse through
on a folder by folder basis so for
example I'm planning my trip to Asia
right now and I have a folder and it's
called you know 2014 Asia trip and
inside I might have you know 25 notes
and in each one I've named it so it
might be you know the cruise ship it
might be Nagasaki it might be Hong Kong
it might be Busan you know each City I
have its own individual note for and all
the information there because how I will
access that information is I'll get my
phone
I should have my phone with me I'll get
my phone
and I'll pull it up and I'll scan from
stock to notebook to note so that'll be
my process will be easy to find that no
pull it up and when I'm in that city I
can usually walk around and find the
things I need to when I'm dealing with
business receipts or legal documents or
any of that stuff I think about again
how do I want to find this information
I'm not typically gonna browse okay I
don't want to browse through my stack
called business receipts and then browse
through my you know notebook which is
you know maybe 2014 q1 q2 and then then
go find mine dividual no because it's
too it's too laborious when I want to
find the receipt I want to be able to
find it so I don't use that browsing
technique and since I'm not using a
browsing technique I don't use I don't
name my files on my business receipts I
just take a picture snap and I'm done
mostly because another way is much
easier to find those receipts so I want
life to be easy I would like to be
simple and so I find that going through
each note and then naming them with
business receipts takes too much time
number three is tags and with tags you
can add keywords to each individual note
that you upload to Evernote and I don't
use tags at all I started using it I
thought hey this is a great way to find
my notes and I was you know tagging each
one of his business it might be the
category of expense or it might be the
the type of expense so it could be like
from the government or could be from a
specific store that I wanted to fly but
it's just ah takes so much work right
for me to do it it's not worth it
it doesn't add enough value because I
can again find the notes through other
means
number four is search this is my
favorite way this is why I love Evernote
because it's so easy to find your files
your notes through their search and if I
had only one method that I would use it
would just be through search so if I'm
trying to find the receipt the reason
why I don't need to name the notes the
reason why I don't need to add tags the
reason why I don't really care so much
about the the category that you know
that the notebook name is because the
search is so good if I need to find
a specific receipt I can just type in
Costco or Business Depot or staples or
McDonald's or whatever it is wherever
you're going it'll pull up that receipt
for you and so I don't care about the
other methods because the search is so
good so quick recap there are four ways
to find your notes it's gonna be from
naming your notebooks naming the notes
adding tags and the search
I only name I will always name the the
notebooks because I find it easy to
browse through them I will only name the
notes if I'm gonna be browsing through
each individual notebook when I'm
traveling for example but not for
business receipts I don't use tags
because it's too much work and you
search all the time because it's so
valuable it's a great question
maybe a little technical let me know
what you guys think if that helped or
not leave a comment below you have more
questions leave a comment let me know
and if you like this video you want to
see more like it
subscribe to the channel then we'll be
more videos coming soon believe I'll see
you soon